We have to get to this week's Patriot male
hatred that mail is when a professional voiceover
artist does interpretive readings of the really
whacked out hatred mail that I get. Here's
a quick reminder about Patriot male
[inaudible].
It's like a mandatory transvaginal ultrasound
for your mind.
Patriot written by patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because freedom,
I uh, this is a shameful week for hatred mail.
You'll see what I mean in a second. Take a
look.
Do you remember this thing called the constitution
and how every president of its obeys it. I'm
ash shammied to say you strip thing parks
men was Liggett. This post proves he's out
to Shill to get hits your biggest hit and
your a shill 636 k move. No chance in hell
636K subscribes. Don't just leave social media.
Leave your show.
Yeah. I would be a sham id to send in a message
like that to a program knowing that it's possible
that it might make it onto the air and the
best thing you can do if you are, it's funny.
Hatred, hate mail motivates, you know, I go
on these rants about membership culture and
supporting the media that we want and disconnecting
advertiser support from the financial viability
of programs that we like and all of this stuff.
And Yeah, some people get motivated to sign
up for membership with that. The amount of
people that sign up as a result of hatred
mail is stunning. It's almost like I should
just play a hatred mail every week and we
would have significantly more membership sign
ups because the best way to fight hatred,
autism is to go to our website, David pakman.com/membership
and sign up with the coupon code hatred at
40 h a t r I o t four zero.
When you do that, you save 40% off of your
membership and it's like a double middle finger
to the hatred. It's telling them, you can
say whatever you want, but we are here and
we are supporting progressive independent
media. Uh, at least that's how I interpret
it. When someone signs up on our website with
the coupon code hatred at 40, I invite you
to do the exact same thing.